This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantu. In 2011, Richard Freeman was working on a project. He was studying the way groups of people work together, specifically how scientists work together. Richard, who's a Harvard economics professor, noticed something intriguing. Scientists in the United States seem to stick to their own kind.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。2011年，理查德·弗里曼正在从事一个项目。他当时在研究人们成群合作的方式，特别是科学家们是如何合作的。理查德是哈佛大学的经济学教授，他注意到一个有趣的现象。美国的科学家似乎倾向于和同类人抱团。
You'd see Chinese folk concentrated in one lab, Indian folk concentrated in another lab, Europeans of different groups, associating more with their compatriots. This was not surprising. You see this kind of clustering in lots of workplaces. But Richard thought, science ought to be different. It general people who are more alike, are likely to think more alike,
你会发现，一个实验室里几乎全是中国面孔，另一个实验室则集中了印度面孔，而不同群体的欧洲人也更多地与同胞交往。这并不奇怪。你在许多职场中都能看到这种聚集现象。但理查德认为，科学应该有所不同。一般而言，更相似的人往往思维方式也更相似，
and one of the things that gives a kick to science and scientific productivity is that you get people with somewhat different views, different perspectives coming together. This assertion has long been debated. Some people say teams with lots of different perspectives come up with better ideas. Others say, no, when a group has lots of different views, this can produce conflict, gridlock. So, which is it? Richard decided to put the question to the test.
而能够推动科学发展和科研生产力的因素之一，正是将那些拥有不同观点、不同视角的人汇聚在一起。这一论点长期以来一直备受争议。有些人认为，拥有各种不同视角的团队能产生更好的创意。另一些人则认为，并非如此，当一个群体有各种各样不同的观点时，反而会产生冲突和僵局。那么，究竟哪个是对的？理查德决定通过实验来验证这个问题。
Do scientists who collaborate with others from the same group produce better science or worse science than scientists who have a wide network of collaborators? To find out, Richard looked at one of the most important signals of scientific success, research publications. He surveyed vast numbers of articles and papers, and he found that in a large number of these papers, co-authors shared a common ethnicity. No surprise. But then he went further.
与来自同一群体的人合作的科学家，其产出的科学成果是更好还是更糟？相比之下，那些拥有广泛合作网络的人呢？为了找到答案，理查德研究了科学成功的最重要的标志之一——研究论文。他调查了大量的文章和论文，发现其中很大一部分论文的共同作者都具有相同的种族背景。这并不奇怪。但他决定进一步深入研究。
There's a very powerful way to judge the quality of scientific papers. The more groundbreaking a paper, the more likely it is to be cited by researchers writing other papers. Cytations, in other words, are a marker of importance. We ask, well, are the papers done by people who are more ethnically the same? Are those papers, do they get more attention? Do they have more citations? Do they appear in journals that are greater prestige? The answer was no. If you write a paper all largely with people of your own group,
有一种非常有力的方法来评判科学论文的质量。一篇论文越具开创性，就越容易被其他撰写论文的研究人员引用。换句话说，引用量是衡量重要性的一个标志。我们不禁要问：由种族背景更单一的人撰写的论文，是否会受到更多关注？它们的引用量是否更高？它们是否会发表在声望更高的期刊上？答案是没有。如果你写一篇论文，其中的合作者大都来自你自己的群体，
it's likely the paper gets less citations than if you write it with a broader group of people. People is that got the most citations, the most prestige, were often written by a mix of people with different backgrounds. It is much better to have people working in collaborating when they're across different laboratories, across different parts of the US, between countries, rather than people
那么这篇论文获得的引用量，很可能不如你和一个更广泛的群体合作撰写的论文。那些获得最多引用、最具声望的论文，往往是由具有不同背景的人共同撰写的。人们跨实验室、跨美国不同地区、甚至跨国进行合作，远比人们仅仅在同一个群体内部闭门造车要好得多。
only working in the same group. Definding hell true, no matter which ethnic groups you look at. This is a result that goes across all the groups. So it's not specific like Chinese guys write a paper together, their paper gets less citations, less impact. The same thing is true if native born, Anglo-Americans do that. In other words, that you're actually at a disadvantage
无论你考察哪个种族群体，这个发现在事实面前都站得住脚。这是一个普遍适用于所有群体的结果。所以它并不是说，比如几个中国学者合写了一篇论文，他们的论文引用量就会变少、影响力就会变低。如果土生土长的盎格鲁-萨克逊美国人这么做，结果也是一样的。换句话说，从某种程度上讲，
if you are surrounded by people of your own group in some ways, regardless of what that group is. Yes, and I think the key thing is to get more ideas, sort of linked together so they can spawn better ideas, as opposed to us all working in the same way. We're going to explore a single idea today that builds upon Richard's finding in science. We look at this idea's applications in the arts, in fashion, and in business. It's about the strange connection between the kind of ideas we dream up and the kind of
如果你被自己群体的人所包围，你实际上处于一种劣势，无论这个群体是什么。是的，我认为关键在于将更多的思想联系和融合在一起，从而催生出更好的想法，而不是让我们所有人都以同一种方式工作。今天，我们将探讨一个基于理查德在科学领域的发现的单一理念。我们将探讨这一理念在艺术、时尚和商业领域的应用。这关乎我们构思的奇思妙想与包围我们的人群之间那种奇妙的联系。
people who surround us. Diversity and creativity. This week on Hidden Brain. In the far northwest of Spain, it's a place of farms and forests and ocean. Galicia. It's a region of rugged coastlines, hardy stews, the Galithian Backpipe. I come from Odense, which is one of the four provinces of Galithia. This is Christina Pato, she's a Backpipe player. When you grew up in Galithia, you grew up hearing music everywhere, hearing music in Abar, hearing music in Asquare, celebrating the festivities of the day or in weddings or in even
多元化与创造力。本周的《隐藏的大脑》。在西班牙的极西北部，那是一个充满农田、森林和海洋的地方。加利西亚。这是一个拥有崎岖海岸线、丰盛炖菜和加利西亚风笛的地区。我来自奥伦塞，它是加利西亚的四个省份之一。这是克里斯蒂娜·帕托，她是一名风笛手。当你成长于加利西亚时，你在成长过程中到处都能听到音乐，在酒吧里能听到音乐，在广场上能听到音乐，在庆祝日常节日、婚礼甚至生日时都能听到音乐。
birthdays. I mean, when you are in Galicia, you pretty much can hear the backpipes almost everywhere. can hear the backpipes almost everywhere. Christina's been playing the backpipes since she was a child. She grew up in a musical household. Her father was an accordion player. Her three older sisters all played the backpipes. And I just wanted to be whatever my sisters were doing. So they began with the backpipes when I was four years old. So I just did it.
我的意思是，当你身处加利西亚时，几乎到处都能听到风笛的声音。几乎到处都能听到风笛的声音。克里斯蒂娜从小就开始吹奏风笛。她在一个音乐世家里长大。她的父亲是一名手风琴手。她的三个姐姐都会吹风笛。而我只是想做我姐姐们在做的事。所以她们开始学风笛时我才四岁。于是我也跟着学了。
The girls were talented. By the time she was 10, Christina and her sister Raquel were traveled to villages to play at festivals. My mother will give us the collision dresses, and then we will start walking in those streets. And the sound of two backpipes at 8am is something that everybody can not only hear, but also recognize.
这些女孩很有天赋。在10岁的时候，克里斯蒂娜和她的姐姐拉克尔就开始到各个村庄的节日上表演了。我母亲会给我们穿上加利西亚的传统连衣裙，然后我们就开始在街道上步行。早晨8点，两把风笛的声音不仅能让每个人都听到，还能被大家辨认出来。
My sister and I will be just waiting for them to come out, play a little Muneera, which is the Galicia National Dance, and people will just start dancing around. As she grew older, Christina began to experiment with her backpipes. She started to play music that wasn't embedded in the folkloric tradition. She started touring with bands. At 18, she released her first solo album. The more Christina stretched, the better she got. By the time her second album was released two years later, she died her hair bright green and acquired a nickname
我和姐姐会等着它们响起，演奏一曲《穆涅拉》（Muneira，加利西亚的民间舞蹈），然后人们就会开始围着我们跳舞。随着年龄的增长，克里斯蒂娜开始尝试用风笛进行创新。她开始演奏那些并非植根于民间传统的音乐。她开始随乐队四处巡演。18岁时，她发行了自己的第一张个人专辑。克里斯蒂娜的尝试越多，她的技艺就越精湛。两年后她的第二专辑发行时，她把头发染成了亮绿色，并获得了一个绰号
The Jimmy Hendrix of the Backpipes For some traditionalists, Christina was stepping over a line. In Galicia, the backpipes remained deeply embedded in tradition. But improvisation came naturally to her. She needed to make her own kind of music. I was trying to just tell people this is what I am and I is not like I don't care about what you think about what I do with my instrument, but there is something about what I do with my instrument that keeps me going. By the time she was a young adult, Christina had to make a choice.
“风笛界的吉米·亨德里克斯”。对于一些传统主义者来说，克里斯蒂娜越界了。在加利西亚，风笛深深植根于传统之中。但即兴创作对她来说是自然而然的。她需要创作属于自己的音乐。我只是想告诉人们，这就是我，并不是说我不在乎别人怎么看我对我的乐器所做的事情，而是我对乐器的这种演奏方式有一种让我不断前进的动力。到了青年时期，克里斯蒂娜面临着一个选择。
It seemed to her like the backpipes could only take her so far. Christina had also been trained in classical piano. In her mid-20s, she decided to leave Spain and go to the United States. She would pursue a mainstream musical career with a piano. And I moved here. I didn't tell anybody around me when I went to Rutgers University to get my doctorate that I had another life. Christina kept her two lives separate. One side of her was a diligent classical music student. The other was still a green-haired back-py player from Galithia.
在她看来，风笛似乎只能带她走到这一步了。克里斯蒂娜还接受过古典钢琴训练。在她20多岁时，她决定离开西班牙前往美国。她将用钢琴追求主流的音乐事业。我搬到了这里。当我前往罗格斯大学攻读博士学位时，我没有告诉周围任何人我还有另一段人生。克里斯蒂娜把她的两面生活分得很开。她的一面是一个勤奋的古典音乐学生顶着绿发的加利西亚风笛手。
player from Galicia. One day in her second semester, a professor asked for help in translating a song. So I get this call from the professor of the vocal department and she says, I have a son in here which is in a language that I believe is closer to Spanish. So I was wondering if you could be the pianist for this singer and also the coach, the vocal coach for diction. And when I see this car, it was Lua de Escolorida, which is literally colorless moon in Galithian. And this was a poem by the most amazing Galam poet of all times, Rosalia de Castro, a female griter of the end of the 19th century.
来自加利西亚的风笛手。在她第二学期的某一天，一位教授请求她帮忙翻译一首歌。于是我接到了声乐系教授的电话，她说：“我这里有一首歌，它的语言据我所知接近西班牙语。”所以我想知道你是否能担任这位歌手的钢琴伴奏，同时担任语音指导。当我看到这张乐谱时，它是《Lua de Escolorida》，在加利西亚语里字面意思是“无色的月亮”。这是一首由19世纪末最伟大的加利西亚女性诗罗莎莉亚·德·卡斯特罗（Rosalia de Castro）创作的诗。
And this composer who, to be honest, I didn't know anything about him, this composer actually has chosen that poem to create music around it. That composer, it turns out, was celebrated, an Argentinian named Oswald or Golihov. She met him at rehearsal. We started talking about Felicia, then he got excited. Then I told him, well, I actually pray the other, the other most important thing about Galicia,
而这位作曲家——老实说，我之前对一无所知——这位作曲家实际上选中了这首诗来为其谱曲。这位作曲家原来是一位著名的阿根廷人，名叫奥斯瓦尔多·戈利霍夫（Osvaldo Golijov）。她在排练时遇到了他。我们开始聊起加利西亚，然后他变得很兴奋。接着我告诉他：“其实我还演奏加利西亚的另一件最重要的东西，
which is Negalicia and Backpipe, and then his eyes opened even wider. Fast forward six months, Christina got a call. It was Oswaldo. He says, why don't you and your husband come to Lenox, as I choose it some some here with some friends being your backpack and yeah, just come and have fun with us. So they did?
那就是加利西亚风笛。”然后他的眼睛睁得更大了。快进六个月，克里斯蒂娜接到了一个电话。是奥斯瓦尔多的。他说：“你和你的丈夫为什么不来伦诺克斯呢？我和一些朋友在这里挑选了一些曲目，带着你的风笛，是的，就来和我们一起玩吧。”于是他们去了。
We arrived in Tanglewood, actually, that's where they were meeting. We see Osvaldo, we started talking and he says, well tonight we are having like gathering in the place where we are staying in Lennogs and I was hoping for you just to show them your instrument, talk a little bit about your tradition, your music, what you do and I'm sure they will love it. So there I was, like playing my instrument with a bunch of strangers that I, the only person I could recognize physically, it was Jojo. Jojo? Jojo. Jojo? Jojo, Jojo, Ma, the cellist.
我们到达了坦格尔伍德，他们其实就是在那儿碰面的。我们见到了奥斯瓦尔德，开始交谈，他说：“今晚我们在伦诺克斯住的地方有一个聚会，我希望你能向大家展示你的乐器，稍微讲讲你们的传统、你的音乐、你的所作所为，我相信他们会喜欢的。”于是我就在那儿，跟一群陌生人一起演奏我的乐器，我能一眼认出来的唯一一个人就是大提琴家。大提琴家？大提琴家。大提琴家？马友友，大提琴家。
The most renowned and famous cellist in the world. What Christina didn't realize was that she'd stumbled into a room filled with master musicians from around the world. They were part of a group created by Jojo Ma. It's a collective known as the Silk Road ensemble, and it brings together musicians from different cultures and different traditions. I kind of was lucky that that night I didn't even know
世界上最著名的杰出大提琴家。克里斯蒂娜没有意识到的是，她误打误撞走进了一个挤满来自世界各地的音乐大师的房间。他们是马友友创建的一个团体的一部分。这是一个名为“丝绸之路合奏团”（Silk Road Ensemble）的集体，它汇集了来自不同文化和传统的音乐家。我很幸运，那天我甚至不知道
who I was playing for because if I did, probably would not have felt so free in the idea of where are these people, what am I doing in front of all of them. I began playing, they started asking questions, I got excited, then I asked them to join and play, and then we ended up that evening, all dancing a Galejian Muneida that I coached them how to dance. And that moment really changed my life in every possible direction, and in that, I didn't even realize how much that moment was going to mean for the rest of my life.
我在为谁演奏，因为如果我知道的话，我可能就不会对“这些人是谁、我在他们所有人面前做什么”这种想法感到那么自如了。我开始演奏，他们开始提问，我兴奋起来，然后我邀请他们加入进来一起演奏，最后那天晚上，我们所有人都跳起了加利西亚的穆涅拉舞，我还教他们怎么跳。那个时刻确实彻底改变了我的人生，而且当时我甚至没有意识到那个时刻将对我的余生产生多么重大的意义。
It was a turning point. Christina joined the Silk Road ensemble. She embraced the vision for the collective, a vision that began with a simple question. What could happen when a stranger's meet? What could happen when strangers meet? This is the question you're your maharast. What could musicians from many different cultures create when they come together. It turns out something extraordinarily beautiful. Jojo Ma describes the work of the collective as something he calls the edge effect. Christina says it's an idea that stuck with her. The edge effect is the pointing which two ecosystems meet like the forest and the savannah and
这是一个转折点。克里斯蒂娜加入了丝绸之路合奏团。她拥抱了该集体的愿景，这个愿景始于一个简单的问题。当陌生人相遇时会发生什么？当陌生人相遇时会发生什么？这就是你所面临的问题。来自许多不同文化的音乐家汇聚在一起时会创造出什么。事实证明，是一些异常美丽的东西。马友友将这个集体的作品描述为他所称的“边缘效应”（the edge effect）。克里斯蒂娜说这是一个深深吸引她的理念。边缘效应是指两个生态系统交汇的点，比如森林和稀树草原，
apparently in ecology in this edge effect is where the most new life forms are created and somehow Silk Road is some sort of his recreation of this edge effect. For Christina, working in that zone where new life forms emerge, that changed the way she saw music. She began to question why Christina, the backpipe player, and Christina, the classical pianist, had to live in different worlds. It's true, the music was different, the traditions were different, even the audiences seemed different. But so what?
显然在生态学中，正是在这种边缘效应中产生了最多样的新生命形式，而丝绸之路在某种程度上就是这种边缘效应的一种再现。对于克里斯蒂娜来说，在那个新生命形式涌现的地带工作，改变了她看待音乐的方式。她开始质疑，为什么风笛手克里斯蒂娜和古典钢琴家克里斯蒂娜必须生活在不同的世界里。诚然，音乐是不同的，传统是不同的，甚至连观众看起来也不同。但这又怎样？
All of us, adding, working with Silrod, I found the connections between the two worlds I've been living on my life that were not even connected in my hometown. And you have to understand also that in Orénse where I come from, the Backpipers School and the Conservatory for Classical Music were two buildings next to each other. This Backpipers School had in a city of a hundred thousand people, had more than ten thousand somehow involved with the Backpipers School. And I could count with the fingers of my hands, the people that could actually go to both,
我们所有人，在加入并与丝绸之路合作的过程中，找到了我在家乡甚至都无法连结的我所生活的两个世界之间的联系。你必须明白，在我出身的奥伦塞，风笛学校和古典音乐音乐学院就是相邻的两栋建筑。在这座十万人口的城市里，风笛学校有超过一万人以某种方式与风笛学校有关联。而我两只手的手指就能数过来，那些既能去上古典音乐培训，又能去学风笛的人。
to go training classical music, but also go train the Zeppelin Piper. Christina says that what drew her was the possibility for connections and conversations between different musical forms. In Silver Road, you also have to keep going and meeting new strangers, meeting new communities, meeting communities of people that you have never imagined of working with. And maybe putting together instruments
克里斯蒂娜说，吸引她的是不同音乐形式之间建立联系和对话的可能性。在丝绸之路，你还必须不断前进，结识新的陌生人，结识新的社群，结识那些你从未想象过与之合作的人群。或许还要将那些
that you will never think they will work together like a Galician backed by panace Japanese, Sakuhachi. the Ambatpai Pana Japanese Sakuhachi. Somehow to me, Silk Road is the metaphor of the 21st century society, or at least to the wish I have for the 21st century society. the free society. The Silk Road musicians have discovered in music what Richard Freeman discovered in science.
你从未想过能组合在一起的乐器结合起来，比如加利西亚风笛和日本尺八。在某种程度上，对我而言，丝绸之路是21世纪社会的隐喻，或者至少是我对21世纪社会的期许。一个自由的社会。丝绸之路的音乐家们在音乐中发现了理查德·弗里曼在科学中发现的东西。
The interesting stuff happens when people from different groups come together. Work together. Collide. When we come back, we'll take a look at the science that explains why diversity and creativity often go hand in hand. Stay with us. Hello, hello, hi, Adam, I'm Shankar. Nice to meet you. Not long ago when I was in New York, I stopped by the apartment of social psychologist Adam Gylinski. When we produced a genie Schmidt and I got there, Adam and his family were waiting for us at the front door.
当来自不同群体的人聚在一起时，有趣的事情就会发生。共同工作。碰撞。当我们回来时，我们将探讨解释为什么创造力和多元化往往齐头并进的科学原理。请继续收听。你好，你好，嗨，亚当，我是尚卡尔。很高兴认识你。不久前我在纽约时，我顺道拜访了社会心理学家亚当·加林斯基（Adam Galinsky）的公寓。当我们和制作人吉妮·施密特（Genie Schmidt）到达那里时，亚当和他的家人正在前门等我们。
Adam lives with his wife, Jen O'Lion, his two young sons, Asher and Aiden, and his mother-in-law, Vicki O'Lion. As we walked into the apartment, Adam made a quick request. Do you want to take it off your shoes? We slipped off our boots, and Adam and Jen pointed to a selection of house shoes they kept under a bench. Here's some slip-wise if you like. Oh great, okay.
亚当和他的妻子珍·奥里昂（Jen O'Lion）、两个年幼的儿子阿什尔（Asher）和艾丹（Aiden），以及他的岳母维基·奥里昂（Vicki O'Lion）住在一起。当我们走进公寓时，亚当提出了一个快速的请求。你想脱鞋吗？我们脱下了靴子，亚当和珍指着他们放在长凳下的精选室内鞋。如果你喜欢的话，这里有些防滑鞋。哦太好了，好的。
Or booties are my favorite. Adam admits that having a shoe-free house wasn't something he'd done growing up. I'd never taken my shoes off in my own house before meeting, you know, dating Jen, and, you know, Jen even doesn't want us to put our clothes on, outside clothes on, sitting on the bed. So, I really integrated this, like, I go to hotels now, and I take off my pants before sitting on the bed. Jen has strong ideas about keeping the inside of a home separate from the outside world.
或者鞋套是我的最爱。亚当承认，家里不穿鞋并不是他成长过程中做过的事。在遇到、你知道的、和珍约会之前，我从来不在自己家里脱鞋，而且，你知道的，珍甚至不让我们把外面的衣服穿到床上去坐。所以，我真的把这一点融入了生活中，比如我现在去酒店，坐在床上之前会先把裤子脱掉。珍对于将家居内部与外部世界隔离开有着强烈的想法。
Over time, Adam has made those ideas his own. I think that that's really made me think about space in a totally different way and sort of how people construct their worlds and their interior environments. And I have much better interior design now in my house than I ever had when I was single. Adam grew up in a secular Jewish family in North Carolina. Jen grew up in Connecticut with parents
随着时间的推移，亚当已经把这些想法变成了他自己的。我认为这确实让我以一种完全不同的方式思考空间，以及人们如何构建他们的世界和室内环境。现在我家的室内设计比我单身时要好得多。亚当在北卡罗来纳州的一个世俗犹太家庭长大。珍在康涅狄格州长大，她的父母是从菲律宾移民过去的。
who'd immigrated from the Philippines. They'd held on to their Filipino culture. Part of that culture includes a deep respect for the home or respect they passed on to Jen. Jen in turn passed on that cultural belief to Adam. I still actually own my apartment in Chicago and I went back to it recently. And I'm like, basically, what a f*** all this was.
他们保留了菲律宾文化。这种文化的一部分包括对家庭的深深尊重——这种尊重被传递给了珍。而珍反过来又将这种文化信仰传给了亚当。我其实还拥有我在芝加哥的公寓，我最近回去过一次。然后我想，基本上，这一切都太糟糕了。
I was just never attentive to all the features of a space that someone who really cares about that in design and how things fit together. And I think that the bedroom now is like, it does feel a little bit more like a sanctuary. And it's almost like you're stepping across, you know, this into this different portal if you will. Jen is also adopted.
我以前从来没有注意到一个真正关心设计以及事物如何组合在一起的人会关注的空间的所有特征。而且我认为现在的卧室确实更像一个避难所。这几乎就像是你正跨越，你知道的，进入这个不同的传送门，如果你愿意的话。珍也被收养了。
Some of Adam's values. Adam has taught me through his Jewish tradition about embracing opening up a feeling, so that labeling, identifying feelings. I tend to mute those things or don't like real conflict. So I don't steer out. Now, you might be asking, what's the big deal? Any time a couple gets together, they blend their lives, embrace some things, let go of others. But here's the difference.
亚当的一些价值观。亚当通过他的犹太传统教导我拥抱、敞开心扉去感受，从而给情感贴上标签、进行识别。我往往会压抑这些事情，或者不喜欢真正的冲突。所以我不会刻意回避。现在，你可能会问，这有什么大不了的？每当一对伴侣走到一起时，他们会融合彼此的生活，拥抱一些东西，放手另一些东西。但不同之处在于：
When people from different countries or cultures come together, it seems to affect their creativity. Adam has studied this topic. We caught up for a longer chat when Jen and the kids weren't around. I wanted to know how he'd gotten interested in the link between diversity and creativity. Adam says it started long ago when he was in high school. Before leaving for a semester abroad, he'd attended a mandatory orientation. Adam says it started long ago when he was in high school. Before leaving for a semester abroad, he'd attended a mandatory orientation. And I still remember to this day, they said, look, summer, you're gonna go to China.
当来自不同国家或文化的人走到一起时，似乎会影响他们的创造力。亚当研究过这个课题。当珍和孩子们不在场时，我们进行了更深入的交谈。我想知道他是如何对多元化与创造力之间的联系产生兴趣的。亚当说，这一切始于很久以前他还在读高中时。在离家进行一个学期的海外交换之前，他参加了一个强制性的新生定向培训。亚当说，这一切始于很久以前他还在读高中时。在离家进行一个学期的海外交换之前，他参加了一个强制性的新生定向培训。而且我至今仍记得，他们说：“听着，暑假你要去中国。”
And in China, it is a sign of respect if you leave food on your plate because it says that you got enough to eat. But in Indonesia, where I was going, it's a sign of disrespect to leave food on your plate because it basically says the food wasn't very good. And so that was sort of eye-opening respect to leave food on your plate because it basically says the food wasn't very good. And so that was sort of eye-opening, transformational experience for me to recognize the same object
“在中国，如果你在盘子里留下一部分食物，这是一种尊敬的标志，因为这说明你吃饱了。”“但在印度尼西亚，也就是我要去的地方，盘子里留食物是不尊重的表现，因为这基本上说明食物不是很好。”所以这可以说是大开眼界。把食物留在盘子里是一种尊重的表现，因为这基本上说明食物不是很好。所以对我来说，那是一次开阔眼界、具有变革意义的经历，让我意识到同一个物体——
food on a plate could have very different meanings and have very different implications depending on the culture. The same thing means different things, depending on your background and perspective. It made Adam wonder how different cultures can help us see the world differently and spark creativity and innovation. Years later, he decided to explore these ideas in a research project. The whole project is a great story because it's a good example of both scientific discovery and scientific collaboration.
盘子里的食物——根据文化的不同，可以有非常不同的含义和截然不同的暗示。同样的事情意味着不同的事情，这取决于你的背景和视角。这让亚当想知道，不同的文化如何能帮助我们以不同的方式看待世界，并激发创造力和创新。多年后，他决定在一个研究项目中探讨这些想法。整个项目是一个很好的故事，因为它既是科学发现又是科学合作的一个优秀范例。
Adam and some colleagues track a group of students at a business school. The researchers hypothesized that the students who showed the most creativity at the end of their school years would also be those who had the most interactions with people from different countries. The collective vast amount of data crunched the results. They were about to publish when... Another group of researchers had actually even a better design than we did and scooped our idea and publish the paper. That should have been the end of it.
亚当和几位同事追踪了一所商学院的一群学生。研究人员假设，在学业结束时表现出最高创造力的学生，也正是那些与来自不同国家的人有最多互动的人。他们收集了海量的数据并对其进行了处理和分析。正当他们准备发表时……另一组研究人员的设计实际上比我们的还要好，抢先了我们的创意并发表了论文。这本该是故事的结局。
Their goal had been to publish and they'd gotten beat. So even though they had a lot of data, they put it all away and moved on. A couple years later, I had a first-year doctoral student in Jackson, Lew, and I said, hey, we have this old data. We can't publish in a great journal because someone already scooped us on it, but we could publish it as a replication simmer good. Why don't you go through the data? What happened next might be an example of the phenomenon Richard Freeman noticed that it helps a research project to have scientists from different ethnicities. Jackson Lew saw something exciting in Adam's data that Adam himself had overlooked. And I said, what's that? And he said, I found this finding that people who had dated someone from another culture became more
他们的目标本来是发表论文，结果却被别人抢先了。因此，尽管他们拥有大量数据，他们还是把数据都收起来并继续前进了。几年后，我带了一名一年级博士生杰克逊·刘（Jackson Lu），我说：“嘿，我们有这些旧数据。我们没法把它发表在顶尖期刊上了，因为别人已经抢先发表了，但我们可以把它作为一项重复性研究发表。你为什么不把这些数据过一遍呢？”接下来发生的事情，或许正是理查德·弗里曼注意到的那种现象的例证：让拥有不同种族背景的科学家参与进来，对一个研究项目大有裨益。杰克逊·刘在亚当的数据中看到了令人兴奋的东西，而这正是亚当本人所忽略的。我说：“那是什么？”他说：“我发现了一个结果，那些与另一种文化背景的人约会过的人，在商学院学习期间变得更有
creative during their business school career, but those who just had friends from another culture didn't seem to become more creative. So there's something unique and wonderful about intercultural romantic relationships. Jackson's enthusiasm made Adam and his colleague sit up. They realized they may have stumbled on something important. Why would dating someone from another culture, spoke creativity? Why would casual friendships not work the same way? So we started thinking again about this idea of deep or the depth and the closeness of those intercultural connections might make a difference.
创造力了，而那些只有异国朋友的人似乎并没有变得更有创造力。”因此，跨文化浪漫关系有着独特而美妙的魔力。杰克逊的热情让亚当和他的同事们精神一振。他们意识到自己可能偶然发现了一些重要的事情。为什么与另一种文化背景的人约会会激发创造力？为什么泛泛的交友无法起到同样的作用？于是我们开始重新思考这个概念，即这些跨文化联系的深度和亲密程度可能会产生影响。
The designed an experiment to test whether the finding was real. This time they reached out only to students who had both dated someone from a different country and dated someone from their own country. The students were then randomly split into two groups. In one condition, we'll ask them to recall their experience they had with their dating someone from their own culture, and just describe that experience. Now, in the other condition, we said, we'll call a time when you dated about one of your relationships with someone from another culture.
他们设计了一个实验来检验这一发现是否真实。这一次，他们只联系了那些既与不同国家的人约过会、又与自己国家的人约过会的学生。然后，学生们被随机分成两组。在一种情况下，我们让他们回忆他们与自己文化背景的人约会的经历，并描述那段经历。而在另一种情况下，我们说：“请回忆一段你与另一种文化背景的人建立恋爱关系的经历。”
What was that experience like? Afterwards, the researchers asked the students to reflect on how much they'd learned about their own and the other culture. And then, they were given a test for creativity. If there was no connection between intercultural romance and creativity, asking the students to reflect on different kinds of encounters should have made no difference. But that's not what the researchers found. We found that there was a boost in temporary creativity just by reflecting on the intercultural relationship, and that was really driven by the fact that people felt that they had learned more about another culture, and that sort of cultural learning that reflection and that
那段经历是怎样的？随后，研究人员要求学生反思他们对自己文化以及另一种文化了解了多少。然后，他们接受了一项创造力测试。如果跨文化恋爱与创造力之间没有联系，那么让学生反思不同类型的相遇应该不会产生任何差异。但研究人员得到的结果并非如此。我们发现，仅仅通过反思跨文化关系，就会带来暂时的创造力提升，而这主要是因为人们觉得他们对另一种文化了解更多了，正是这种文化学习、这种反思以及那种
culture learning led to increased creativity. Psychology research out of Tufts University has found something similar. When you introduce racial diversity into a group, all the people in the group begin to broaden the scope of their thinking and to explore more options. Now, creativity can be difficult to measure, but scientists have devised ways of doing it. Typically, they analyze what they call, divergent thinking and convergent thinking. And convergent creativity tasks or ones in which there's a single right answer. And one of the most famous examples of a single right answer that we didn't
文化学习带来了创造力的提升。来自塔夫茨大学（Tufts University）的心理学研究也发现了类似的结果。当你向一个群体引入种族多元化时，该群体中的所有人都会开始拓宽思维视野并探索更多选项。现在，创造力可能很难衡量，但科学家们已经设计出了方法。通常情况下，他们分析所谓的发散性思维和收敛性思维。收敛性创造力任务是指那些只有一个正确答案的任务。我们在这个特定项目中没有实际使用、
actually use in this particular project, but I've used them many of our other studies, is the Dunker Candle problem. And the Dunker Candle problem, you ask people to, you give them a candle, a box of tax, and a book of matches. And you tell them, fix the candle to a wall in such way that the candle when lit doesn't rip wax onto the wall, table, or floor. Adam says that when he tried this with a group of smart, undergraduate Princeton, only a small percentage of the students solved the problem within 15 minutes.
但我在其他许多研究中使用过的、只有一个正确答案的最著名例子之一，就是邓克尔蜡烛问题（Dunker Candle problem）。在邓克尔蜡烛问题中，你要求人们——你给他们一支蜡烛、一盒图钉和一盒火柴。你告诉他们：“把蜡烛固定在墙上，使得蜡烛点燃时，蜡油不会滴到墙壁、桌子或地板上。”亚当说，当他让普林斯顿大学一群聪明的本科生做这个实验时，只有极小比例的学生在15分钟内解出了这个问题。
The reason is that the test requires you to think about familiar objects in a new way. A box of tax can be a repository for tax, but can also be a stand. And the solution is you dump out all the tax out of the box, you tack the box to the wall, and then you put the candle inside. Divergent tasks don't ask for a single right answer. They require you to produce lots of different ideas. In our study, we ask people at time one, when we first measure their creativity, to generate as many creative uses as they can for brick. And then at time two, when they graduated from business school,
原因在于，这个测试要求你以一种新的方式思考熟悉的对象。一盒图钉可以用来装图钉，但也可以是一个底座。而解决方案是：你把盒子里的所有图钉倒出来，把盒子用图钉固定在墙上，然后把蜡烛放进盒子里。发散性任务不要求单一的正确答案。它们要求你产生许多不同的想法。在我们的研究中，我们在时间点一（即我们首次测量他们的创造力时）要求人们尽可能多地想出一块砖的创意用途。而在时间点二（即他们从商学院毕业时），
we asked them to think about as many creative uses they could for a box. And then you can code these uses for the number of uses they come up with. But you can also code them for the number of different categories they come up with. So for a brick, someone might say, oh, it could be used as a piece of furniture. So that's one category. Or it could be used as the weapon. You could throw it at someone, that's another category, or it could be used as part of a house, that's another category. Again, generating lots of good ideas is a sign of a creative brain. In the study of business school students, Adam and his colleagues gave the volunteers one final task. It's called the Remote Associates Test.
我们要求他们想出一个纸箱尽可能多的创意用途。然后你可以对这些用途进行编码，看他们想出了多少种用途。但你也可以对它们进行编码，看他们想出了多少个不同的类别。比如对于砖块，有人可能会说：“哦，它可以被用作一件家具。”所以这是一个类别。或者它可以被当成武器。你可以把它扔向某人，这是另一个类别；或者它可以被用作房屋的一部分，这是又一个类别。同样，产生许多好的想法是一个具有创造力的大脑的标志。在对商学院学生的研究中，亚当和他的同事们给志愿者们布置了最后一项任务。它被称为“远程联想测验”（Remote Associates Test）。
Where you get people three words, and then you ask them basically to find the one word that connects them. And one of the classic examples that people give is you're given these three words, manner, round, and tense. And you've got to come up with the one word that connects all three of them. And in this case the answer is table. Why? You can have table manners, you can have round tables, and you can have table tennis. What Adam and his colleagues found is that in every one of these tests, the group of volunteers randomly selected to reflect on their experience dating someone from another country,
在这个测验中，你给人们三个词，然后基本上要求他们找出能够将这三个词连结起来的一个词。人们给出的经典例子之一是：给你这三个词——“manner”（礼仪/方式）、“round”（圆的/周围）和“tense”（时态/紧张的）。你必须想出一个将这三者联系起来的词。在这个例子中，答案是“table”（桌子）。为什么？你可以有“table manners”（餐桌礼仪），你可以有“round tables”（圆桌），你还可以有“table tennis”（乒乓球）。亚当和他的同事们发现，在每一个这样的测试中，被随机选出、反思其与另一个国家的人约会经历的志愿者群体，
outperformed those asked to reflect on their experience dating someone from their own country. They increased in their flexibility and novelty of their ideas, and basically in our final data what we did is we basically created a single composite creativity score, which really collapsed across all these, but the same effect actually emerges on each of the individual problems which shows how robust and powerful the effect was. The findings were intriguing. The researchers decided to go a step further. They wanted to know if the results would hold up in the real world.
其表现都优于那些被要求反思与自己国家的人约会经历的群体。他们的想法在灵活性和新颖性上都有所增加，基本上在我们最终的数据中，我们所做的是创建了一个单一的复合创造力评分，它真正涵盖了所有这些测试，但实际上在每一个单独的问题上也出现了相同的效果，这表明该效应是多么稳健和强大。这些发现引人入胜。研究人员决定更进一步。他们想知道这些结果在现实世界中是否依然成立。
They were wondering how to do that when one day Adam went to a presentation given by his colleague Dan Wong. And here's presenting this great amazing data set of everyone who had a J1 visa to visit the US and he was able to survey them. J1 visas allow people to work in the United States for a defined period of time, usually between three months and two years. At any given time, there are about 300,000 J1 visa holders. So that means that we have tons of people who have come to the US for a relatively short period time, but you know up to 24 months, almost two years, and then return back to their home country.
他们正在琢磨该怎么做时，有一天亚当去听了他的同事丹·王（Dan Wong）的一个演讲。丹在那里展示了一个非常棒、令人惊叹的数据集，涵盖了所有持有J-1签证访问美国的人，并且他能够对他们进行调查。J-1签证允许人们在美国工作一段确定的时间，通常在三个月到两年之间。在任何给定时间，大约有30万名J-1签证持有人。这意味着我们有大量的人来到美国相对较短的一段时间（长达24个月，也就是差不多两年），然后返回他们的祖国。
After the talk, Adam went up to Dad and asked him, if by any chance, he had any data on cross-cultural contact and the depth of those connections. He said, I think I do. It turned out, Dan had us former J1 visa holders this question. Please report the frequency of contact that you have with your American friends since you have returned to your home country. The survey also asked the former visa holders what kind of work they'd been doing since returning home.
演讲结束后，亚当走到丹面前，问他碰巧是否有关于跨文化接触及其联系深度的任何数据。他说：“我想我有的。”事实证明，丹曾向这些前J-1签证持有人提出过这样一个问题：“请报告自从您返回祖国以来，您与美国朋友保持联系的频率。”该调查还询问了这些前签证持有人自回国以来一直在从事什么样的工作。
Adam has done to take a look at his data and see if there was a correlation between those who'd maintained the closest contact with their American friends and whether they became an entrepreneur when they got home and founded their own company and whether they had created new practices in their company when they got home and founded their own company, and whether they had created new practices in their company when they got home. Indeed there was. He said, oh my God, the data are exactly as you would have predicted, and so that was really the icing on the cake of this paper.
亚当着手查看这些数据，看看那些与美国朋友保持最紧密联系的人与他们回国后是否成为创业者、是否创办了自己的公司之间是否存在相关性，以及他们回国后是否在公司里创造了新的实践。确实如此。他说：“哦天哪，数据正如你所预测的那样，这真的是这篇论文锦上添花的部分。”
We'd already had this great data from laboratory-based paper and pencil creativity measures, but now we have the core of our hypothesis, that the depth of intercultural relationships, the frequency which they had contact predicts these real world, consequential creativity measures, the probability that they became an entrepreneur and started their own business and how much they changed and transformed and innovated in their own companies. This time, Adam and his colleagues did not get scooped. They got published.
我们已经拥有了基于实验室的纸笔创造力测量方法的出色数据，但现在我们有了假说的核心支撑——跨文化关系的深度、他们联系的频率，能够预测这些现实世界中具有重大意义的创造力指标，即他们成为企业家并创办自己公司的概率，以及他们在各自公司中改变、转型和创新的程度。这一次，亚当和他的同事们没有被抢先。他们的论文成功发表了。
Adam says he sees more and more links between creativity and cultural diversity. You bet I'll work. In one of his favorite projects, he looked at fashion lines presented by major fashion houses over 21 seasons. Milan, Paris, London, and New York. He found that there appeared to be a connection between creativity and the time that fashion creators had spent immersed in a different culture. And what we found was something really interesting, which is that the amount of time that the creative
亚当说，他看到创造力与文化多元化之间的联系越来越多。你可以确信我会致力于此。在他最喜欢的项目之一中，他研究了各大时装屋在21个季度里推出的时装系列。米兰、巴黎、伦敦和纽约。他发现，创造力与时装设计师沉浸于不同文化中的时间之间似乎存在着某种联系。而我们发现了一些非常有趣的事情，那就是创意
director had worked abroad predicted their entire fashion line creativity, but not the number of countries that they worked abroad. That didn't have near as much of an impact as the amount of time that they worked abroad. All these examples have a common thread. The fashion designers look a lot like the students at Business School who dated someone from another country. The students look a lot like the scientists who spend time collaborating with partners from different ethnicities. The musicians who work with someone from a different tradition have something in common with the entrepreneurs who make broad connections and spend time maintaining them. What all these cross cultural relationships have is depth.
总监在海外工作的时间能够预测其整个时装系列的创造力，但他们在多少个国家工作过却不能。后者对创造力的影响远远不及他们在海外工作的时间长短。所有这些例子都有一个共同的线索。时装设计师看起来很像商学院里与另一个国家的人约会过的学生。这些学生看起来很像那些花时间与不同种族背景的伙伴合作的科学家。那些与来自不同传统的人合作的音乐家，与那些建立广泛联系并花时间维护这些联系的企业家有着共同之处。所有这些跨文化关系都具备的共同点是：深度。
There's something about deeply understanding and learning about another culture that's transformative. We can get that from living abroad. We can get that from dating someone from another culture. We could even get it from traveling, but only if we really learned and understood and embraced and adapted to that other culture why we were traveling abroad.
深刻理解并了解另一种文化具有某种变革性的力量。我们可以从海外生活中获得这一点。我们可以从与另一种文化背景的人约会中获得这一点。我们甚至可以从旅行中获得这一点，但前提是我们真的去了解、理解、拥抱并适应了那种异质文化，在我们出国旅行期间。
And so I think the big scientific conclusion that is very robust is that it's about really, truly, deeply understanding another culture is the key to enhancing your own creativity. Adam Galinsky and his wife, Jen, say they want their children to see the world in this expansive way. At Adam says, the beauty of his research is that it suggests the benefits of broad collaboration are within easy reach, especially in the United States. You don't have to go abroad to get some of the creativity benefits of having that intercultural contact. You can get that same benefit here in the United States by embracing engaging with people from other cultures. But again, there's the catch.
因此，我认为一个非常稳健的重大科学结论是：真正、深刻地理解另一种文化，是提升你自身创造力的关键。亚当·加林斯基和他的妻子珍表示，他们希望自己的孩子以这种广阔的视角看待世界。正如亚当所说，他的研究之美在于它表明，广泛合作的好处触手可及，尤其是在美国。你不必出国就能获得拥有这种跨文化接触所带来的一些创造力益处。通过拥抱和参与与其他文化的交往，你在美国本土就能获得同样的益处。但话说回来，这里有个问题。
It can't just be superficial. You've got to more deeply connect the people from other cultures to have that transformational impact in that experience. You could argue there are limitations in some of the examples we've discussed today. It's possible that scientists who collaborate with diverse teams or musicians who team up with performers from other traditions, these people might just be risk-takers.
这不能只是表面的。你必须与来自其他文化的人建立更深层次的联系，才能产生那种变革性的影响和体验。你可能会认为我们今天讨论的一些例子存在局限性。有可能那些与多元化团队合作的科学家，或是那些与来自其他传统的表演者组队的音乐家，这些人本身就只是喜欢冒险的人。
In other words, it's not the musical collaborations that make you more creative, it's just having an open outlook. It's very difficult to explore questions like this scientifically. We can't conduct experiments where we dictate who people date or who scientists should collaborate with. But I would argue that even in studies where you can't prove cause and effect, you can still see the effects that diversity has on creativity. And this is not just at the level of individuals, it's at the level of communities, even nations. Consider this.
换句话说，不是音乐合作让你变得更有创造力，而只是因为你拥有开放的心态。用科学的方法探讨这类问题非常困难。我们无法进行由我们来决定谁跟谁约会、或者科学家应该和谁合作的实验。但我认为，即便在那些无法证明因果关系的的研究中，你仍然可以看到多元化对创造力的影响。这不仅体现在个人层面，还体现在社群层面，甚至国家层面。试想一下：
The United States, a country that accounts for about 5% of the world's population, has won about 60% of all the Nobel Prizes ever awarded. From the motor car and the airplane, to Facebook and Google, from the telephone and the internet to Hollywood and Wall Street, scientists, entrepreneurs and entertainers from the United States have powerfully shaped the world in which we live.
美国，这个仅占世界人口约5%的国家，却赢得了所有诺贝尔奖中大约60%的奖项。从汽车和飞机，到Facebook和谷歌，从电话和互联网，到好莱坞和华尔街，来自美国的科学家、企业家和演艺人员以强有力的方式塑造了我们今天生活的这个世界。
Could some of this outside's creativity have to do with the extraordinary diversity of America, the waves of immigrants who arrived here over the centuries? I'd like to think the answer is yes. Today's episode was produced by Jenny Schmidt and Path Shah and edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Raina Cohen, Thomas Liu, Laura Quarell, and Kat Chuknik. The song you're listening to right now is Volio. It's composed by Christina Pado and Kogira Umazaki.
这种外部创造力是否与美国非凡的多样性、几个世纪以来到达这里的移民潮有关？我愿意相信答案是肯定的。今天的节目由珍妮·施密特和帕斯·沙阿制作，塔拉·博伊尔编辑。我们的团队包括雷娜·科恩、托马斯·刘、劳拉·夸雷尔和卡特·丘克尼克。你现在听到的这首歌是《Volio》。它由克里斯蒂娜·帕多和小栗马崎创作。
It blends the Japanese Sakohachi with the Galithian Batpipe. Thanks to the team at WNYC's Soundcheck for sharing this recording with us. This week, our unsung hero is Lynette Clemetson. Lynette is currently director of the Night Wallace Fellowships program for journalists, but before that, she was a beloved colleague here at NPR. She believes, with every bone in her body, in the link between diversity and creativity. Lynette was an early and ardent supporter of hidden brain, where literally would not exist without her. In fact, I can't believe we haven't previously
它融合了日本尺八和加利西亚风笛。感谢 WNYC Soundcheck 团队与我们分享这段录音。本周，我们默默无闻的英雄是林内特·克莱梅特森。林内特目前是面向记者的奈特-华莱士奖学金项目的总监，但在那之前，她是NPR备受爱戴的同事。她深信多样性与创造力之间存在着必然联系。林内特是《隐藏的大脑》早期坚定的支持者，如果没有她，这个节目简直无法存在。事实上，我真不敢相信我们之前没有
called her out as an unsung hero. Of course, that is precisely what makes her an unsung hero. If you like today's show, please share it with one friend who comes from a different cultural background. Tell us about your conversation on Facebook and Twitter. I'm Shankar Vidantantham, and this is NPR. I'm going to have to go. I'm going to have to go. I'm going to have to go. I'm going to have to go. I'm going to have to go.
称赞她为默默无闻的英雄。当然，这正是她成为无名英雄的原因。如果你喜欢今天的节目，请把它分享给一位有着不同文化背景的朋友。在 Facebook 和 Twitter 上与我们分享你的对话。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这里是 NPR。我得走了。我得走了。我得走了。我得走了。我得走了。
I'm going to have to go. I'm going to have to go. I'm going to have to go. I'm going to have to go. I'm going to have to go. I'm going to have to go. I'm going to have to go. I'm going to have to go. I'm going to have to go. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我得走了。我得走了。我得走了。我得走了。我得走了。我得走了。我得走了。我得走了。我得走了。谢谢。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。